nach der blutigen messerattacke in
stolberg bei aachen am frühen
sonntagmorgen konnte die polizei später
einen verdächtigen festnehmen
auf twitter schreibt sie der gesuchte
content stolberg in einem fahrzeug als
beifahrer durch ein mobiles
einsatzkommando festgenommen werden und
davon sehen wir jetzt hier
gerade auch die bilder darüber möchte
ich sprechen mit meinem kollegen frank
schneider mir nun zugeschaltet frank was
genau ist bei dieser messerattacke
geschehen
ja man muss sagen es ist das opfer mit
langsamen fahrt geschwindigkeit und
stolper gefahren und dann ist dieser
täter an das fahrzeug heran getreten hat
die fahrertür aufgerissen
ob es vorher zu einer verabredung zu
haben ob das eine gezielte falle war ob
das opfer dorthin gelockt war das ist
noch unklar
jedenfalls hat der täter dann die tür
aufgerissen hat massiv auf das opfer
versucht einzustechen der hat sich
gewehrt die entschuldigung nähert sich
gewehrt und hat dann daraufhin mehrere
ganz schwere schnittverletzungen
stichverletzungen im bereich erhalten
dabei auch noch große blutgefäße
verletzt und deswegen musste das opfer
dann auch notoperiert werden damit es
nicht verblutet jetzt haben egal die
bilder der festnahme gesehen kennt man
jetzt schon hintergründe der tat
das ist ein sehr muss man sagen
verrückter zusammenhang schon fast denn
es soll so sein dass der täter auch den
jungen mann eingestochen hat weil er der
sohn eines deutsch türkin ist der auf
einem fdp plakat wo der kommunalwahl
mehr oder weniger werbung für die afg
gemacht hat und danach kursierten im
netz
dieses plakat mit der überschrift dass
eine islamische partei und alle die dort
sozusagen werbung für diese partei
machen würden seien kuba also ungläubige
und müssten bestraft werden und diesen
zusammenhang prüft jetzt die polizei ob
dem wirklich so ist
die polizei köln hat diesen diese
ermittlungen übernommen weil es sich
eben hierbei um ein sogenanntes
anschlagsszenario handelt und die
polizei köln ist die übergeordnete
behörde für den bereich dort liegt ja
stolberg und die ermittlungen laufen auf
hochtouren man muss vielleicht noch eins
zum täter sagen er ist bekannt als
mitglied der salafistischen also
islamistischen szene galt auch bei der
polizei hat so genannter islamischer
prüfen
diese islamistischen prüfstelle auch
weil kurz zur erklärung sind personen wo
man befürchtet könnten
zu gewalttaten neigen ja und das hat
sich nun mal leider auch schrecklicher
art und weise bestätigt und seit dieser
tag gestern und seiner festnahme gilt er
jetzt als gefährder ist natürlich ein
kleiner moment zu spät aber er sitzt
jetzt zum glück in gewahrsam soll heute
dem haftrichter vorgeführt werden und
vielleicht wird man in seiner aussage
noch genau erfahren was jetzt
hintergrund das motiv für die tat sind
ob es sich darum handelt was die polizei
momentan vermutet vielen dank frank
schneider für diese information
dankeschön
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren